[Music]
now hospital visits are nothing new to
the cast of Dancing with the Stars and
neither are show man's groomers but is
the steamy gossip just a ploy to get
votes well that's what we wanted to know
when Shauna shared her plan to win it
all with et online lauren zima
they sat down for a Facebook live
conversation what is your strategy to
win take each day as it comes really uh
with Vonda honestly my strategy is to
just have him improve as much as we can
each weekend and I think my goal for him
is to have him moving better with his
injuries Shauna admits that strategy
took a bit of a hit last night
I did not expect to have Charleston
thrown at me so early in the season to
be honest it was a huge curveball an
interesting choice for a man that's
broken his neck only 12 months ago you
didn't do it that well I think you could
have given a little bit more did that
feel a little bit unfair to have that
thrown at you it did honestly it did
feel a little bit unfit he wakes up with
pain he dances with pain he goes to
sleep with pain so how do they bounce
back well expect that is there something
more happening between these two off the
dance floor angle to stick around
dancing isn't just dancing it's acting
well everyone wants that chemistry to be
maybe romantic or something else we're
not necessarily trying to play into it
but we do have fun together and we have
a great time and I guess we look good
together you know and so that the
storyline goes a certain way and if that
doesn't work
Charlotte's got a secret weapon ready to
go I'm not really one for doing
shirtless all the time we're trying to
be overly sexy with the costumes but you
know it's gonna come Bonta has such a
gorgeous body that I think everyone's
waiting for me to rip that shirt open
this I'm holding a hostage guys okay
hostage keep voting or her team denim
and diamonds because it's gonna come if
you want abs you have to fart yep that
is certainly one way to get the vote
[Music]
you